meta builds a humongous computer openai
teaches their language models to follow
instructions and we battle pigeons with
drones welcome to ml news
[Music]
hello and welcome to ml news now i have
to say these aren't exactly news this is
stuff that we've somehow missed or
skipped or anything like this from the
last two to three weeks let's say so
consider this more ml olds but if you're
interested stick around if you actually
do enjoy new ml news be sure to be
subscribed to the channel leave a like
and as always tell me what you think in
the comments i'm very happy to take your
feedback first story meta ai has
released a blog post introducing the ai
research super cluster meta's cutting
edge ai supercomputer for ai research
now this
this is a big computer like look at that
the rsc the the research super cluster
that is ginormous i mean
look at this does anyone get the vibes
of like so this is where your box would
go
in any case this is a huge thing it
consists of
760 dgx a100 boxes that is a total of
6080 gpus and all of them are a100s but
did you wonder why you couldn't get your
hands on any gpu anywhere on the planet
for the last one and a half years or so
yeah they're all right here now
obviously obviously all of this is
connected with super duper infiniband it
has 175 petabytes of storage it has a
175 petabytes of a flash array storage
has 46 petabytes of cash storage and it
has 10 petabytes of flash blade storage
i have no clue what these things mean
but it's a lot so the blog post goes a
little bit into the history of how it
was built a bit more what it contains
how they make it secure how they handle
the difficulties of the last two years
and so on this cluster is supposed to
support meta ai's production and
research workloads and is already
operational but is planned to finish to
its full scale up to the
mid-2022 look here's the box here's the
box where does the box go
where does your box go
your box goes there
really nice this is where your box would
go check out blog post if you want to
learn more
openai has released a blog post and
paper titled aligning language models to
follow instructions where they've
fine-tuned gpt3 to follow human
instructions they give an example right
here where if you ask gpt3 something
like explain the moon landing to a
six-year-old in a few sentences it would
sort of continue the pattern as gpt3
does it would say explain the theory of
gravity explain the theory of relativity
so it would it would sort of treat this
as a regular language modeling problem
if you actually want to make gpt3 answer
the question you have to give it a few
examples of question answer question
answer beforehand openlyai went and
fine-tuned their language models to obey
instructions more clearly so the model
that results is instruct gpt which in
this case would output people went to
the moon they took pictures of what they
saw and sent them back to earth so we
could all see them supposedly
like yeah like that ever happened so the
main challenge here is the data
collection part fine-tuning a big
language model requires a bit of data
and they largely followed earlier work
called learning from human preferences
so this is a multi-step process first
they collect a small labeled data set
after that they let humans sort of rank
answers of the model and they train a
reward model from that and in the end
they use reinforcement learning against
that learned reward model now in their
own words this is nothing new they say
however the smaller instruct gpt model
are preferred by humans to the larger
gpt-3 models which is interesting
there's a paper to go along with it give
it a read if you are interested
meta-ai writes that they are releasing a
series of multilingual auto regressive
language models up to 7.5 billion
parameters which significantly
outperform english-centric language
models in few shot learning on 20 plus
languages again there is a paper to go
along with it and the code and models
are available on the repository these
are multilingual models and most of the
models are trained on 30 different
languages as you can see they do scale
up in partially layers also model
dimensions and there's even one model
that's trained on over 134
languages so if you're interested in
multilingual models give this model a
try
google releases a paper called lambda
language models for dialogue
applications along with a blog post
where they detail a new foray into
dialogue models using large language
models now interestingly here is that
they're not only interested in
generating the most likely data they do
pre-train on pure language modeling but
then when it comes to fine-tuning on
dialogue data they have various metrics
and for each of these metrics they have
classifiers that classifies the outputs
of the language model which is trying to
optimize so some of these outputs are
safety sensibility specificity
interestingness and so on the model is
also capable of doing factual grounding
as it is augmented by a retrieval stage
during the generation process so
technically it can look up something on
wikipedia before it answers you which is
pretty cool if you're interested in
dialogue models definitely give this
blog post and paper a read
[Music]
all right some helpful stuff for this
week evolution gym is a large-scale
benchmark for evolving soft robots so
contrary to classic reinforcement
learning where your agent is kind of
fixed and static and has a bunch of
actions available in soft robots you can
also choose how to compose your robot so
here's a bunch of examples of soft
robots
now as you can see the policy isn't the
hard part it's actually the hard part
how you even construct your robots from
the individual building blocks so here
you can see a walker there is object
manipulation climbing i believe they do
have some some other examples right here
there's climbing
that looks pretty cool so even though
it's still in reinforcement learning
this is a cool domain i like it there's
a paper to go along with the release if
you're interested in soft robotics and
reinforcement learning give it a read
stable bass lines three is in the
hugging phase hub stable baselines three
is a reinforcement learning library that
provides kind of baseline
implementations of rl algorithms such as
proximal policy optimization q-learning
and more so now these are on the hogging
face hub and you can just kind of
download the strategies maybe not
entirely sure but if you're into
reinforcement learning give this a try
i've seen that scentdex has already made
a video using stable baselines 3 but as
far as i could see he has not used the
hugging face hub so sorry harrison you
actually did like a lot of work for
nothing you like pip installed the
actual package
why in related news i want to highlight
this repository right here by alejandro
fonvera who released this repository to
perform reinforcement learning with
transformers it's a library slash
example code repository of training
transformers using proximal policy
optimization if you don't know proximal
policy optimization is a reinforcement
learning algorithm that tries to
maximize the reward but at the same time
stay close to some known state like a
baseline implementation a baseline model
or a previous version of the model that
you're training this prevents
fatal steps like single steps that bring
you into really bad local minima i was
going to say if you're into the
combination of language and
reinforcement learning check this out
but i mean transformers have gone way
beyond language by this point so if
you're into rl and transformers this
might be the repo for you okay this was
it for our helpful stuff this week i
hope you were helped our next news is
google ai releasing a blog post called
accurate alpha matting for portrait mode
selfies on pixel 6. yes it is a bit of
an ad for their pixel phones but also it
details quite extensively how they went
about training a system that would
generate the alpha matte for the types
of portrait pictures so the goal here is
to get a mask on top of a picture that
separates foreground meaning if it's a
portrait the person from background so
that you can swap out the background
this is challenging because as you can
see right here hair is often a problem
there are very fine details the lighting
can come from any place and that might
not match up with the background and so
on so they detail what kind of model
architecture they did it consists of
progressive up sampling which we've seen
a couple of times so far and the most
interesting part is the data generation
process they have this giant studio with
like surround array of cameras and
lights so they can activate different
lights at different times and get kind
of a 3d impression of the subject that
is at the center they're also able to
capture different lighting effects on
the subject which is also really helpful
because the second thing they do is they
place that subject into various kind of
fake backgrounds and these fake
backgrounds are not just any picture
they are sort of 360 pictures of scenes
so what they can do is they can
dynamically re-light the subject so that
it actually fits into the background and
from that they generate the training
data to the alpha matte classifier now
give this a read if you want to learn
more i was just impressed how deep one
can go in like a single task like how
much there is if you really want to
solve something to the level of where
you can build it into a product and it
performs well so that's pretty cool
i saw this article on ieee explorer
called autonomous detection and
deterrence of pigeons on buildings by
drones and this is the most metal thing
ever i mean poor drones so there's this
camera on roofs and it locates pigeons
and when it sees a flock of them pigeons
would destroy their things with their
well they call it excrements but it's
poop so they poop and it destroys the
buildings so they want to shoo them away
to prevent damage and difficult and
dangerous cleaning procedures so the
camera spots the pigeons and it sends in
the drone and here you can see like a
first person view of the drone is like
it waits and it's like activate it just
goes after the pigeons
i'm so sorry pigeons machines won nature
zero your move pigeons
all right our last news bloomberg writes
ibm sells some watson health assets for
more than one billion dollars so
apparently the whole watson project
hasn't really panned out for ibm the way
they wanted it to after the initial
successes of winning jeopardy it just
kind of got nowhere it seemed like i've
heard from a lot of people that it was
just not doing the things they promised
it to do when they actually deployed it
in let's say health settings or or the
finance world i don't know exactly what
they tried but the uniform feedback i've
heard is that it just underwhelmed in
practice now there are some customers
using it and ibm says it's still
committed to the project note that it is
only selling some parts and only of
watson health that is not the entire
watson project it's just a health sub
project which might come with its own
difficulties let's say regulatory and
whatnot also ibm says that it is going
to focus more on being a cloud provider
for ai applications well i guess that's
where the big money is right now i guess
if you're a cloud provider now you can
just you can just print money so good on
ibm instead of losing money they're now
printing it excellent this was already
it for ml news if you have any comments
anything to say please leave it in the
comments merch still available and i'll
see you next time bye bye
[Music]
you